hoy vamos a hablar sobre chile un país
que es como si argentina se hubiera
puesto a dieta de adelgazamiento los
beiges están los dos juntitos argentina
es el gordo chile es el delgado son como
los blues brothers de los países esto
que os digo no es ninguna tontería al
tener una forma tan estrecha chile tiene
menos porcentaje de tierra cultivable
que un país como yemen que está en mitad
del desierto además como está aislado
por la cordillera de los andes sigue lo
tiene muy difícil para poder comerciar
con el resto de países sin embargo y
pese a todo es el lugar más rico de toda
latinoamérica y porque os estamos
hablando de chile hoy os preguntaréis
bueno lo cierto es que chile que sólo
tiene 20 millones de habitantes es un
país con una gran carga simbólica para
los liberales es un ejemplo de como el
libre mercado funciona y para los
socialistas es el motor del capitalismo
cuál de los dos tiene razón hoy vamos a
verlo
y hay muchas teorías conspiranoicas
sobre supuestos gobiernos puestos o de
puestos por eeuu incluso alguno nos ha
llegado a decir en los comentarios que
nosotros estamos pagados por la cia que
tiene narices sin embargo el golpe de
estado de pinochet en 1973 es uno de los
pocos casos que están perfectamente
documentados y hasta reconocidos por el
propio washington de que tuvieron
influencia de la fia por aquel entonces
chile estaba presidido por salvador
allende que era un político apoyado por
el partido comunista y con mucha
simpatía por la unión soviética la baja
política de mi gobierno está formada por
marc cita por laicos y cristianos como
os podéis imaginar este tipo de
discursos en plena guerra fría hicieron
saltar las alarmas de la casa blanca que
por aquel entonces tenía en el despacho
oval a un presidente como richard nixon
un político muy conocido por sus pocos
escrúpulos a la hora de atacar a sus
rivales políticos así que en menos de lo
que canta un gallo los chicos de la cia
estaban en santiago de chile- buscando
algún general dentro del ejército
chileno dispuesto a dar un golpe de
estado así es cómo surgió la figura de
augusto pinochet
es un hijo de [ __ ] pero es nuestro hijo
de [ __ ] en 1973 pinochet toma el palacio
de la moneda y elimina a todos sus
rivales políticos literalmente de hecho
convirtió el estadio de fútbol de
santiago de chile en un campo de
concentración improvisado en el que
asesinó a más de 300 personas
los 17 años que duró su dictadura fueron
asesinados o desaparecieron
misteriosamente más de 3000 personas en
lo que respecta a la economía los
primeros años de pinochet fueron
catastróficos la inflación llegó a rozar
los 300 puntos para que os hagáis una
idea llegó un momento donde con el
salario mínimo sólo te daba para comprar
el pan de un mes y es en este momento
donde la junta militar de pinochet se ve
obligada a buscar ayuda en un grupo de
economistas formados en la universidad
católica de chile pero muy influidos por
dos economistas americanos que se
llamaban milton friedman y arnold
harberger por eso se les llamó los
chicago boys tanto friend and como
harberger eran conocidos en todo el
mundo por sus posiciones a favor del
libre mercado pero de todo eso vamos a
hablar en otro vídeo
los principios del ejército son de
arriba hacia abajo mientras que los
principios del mercado son de abajo
hacia arriba el auténtico milagro es que
un grupo de militares estuviera
dispuesto a aceptar una perspectiva de
abajo hacia arriba ya que en pocos años
los chicago boys transformaron la
economía chilena de arriba a abajo
privatizaron muchas de las empresas
públicas acabaron con la inflación y
hasta cambiaron el sistema de pensiones
público por 1 capitalizado uno de los
pocos que existen en el mundo el
resultado a corto plazo es que se
perdieron miles de puestos de trabajo de
empresas poco eficientes que estaban
auspiciadas por el estado
además se cortaron muchas de las ayudas
públicas que había para los más pobres
aunque vamos a ser honestos realmente
llevaban años sin poderse pagar porque
no había dinero lo cierto es que tras
unos años de shock la década de los 80
fue muy buena para la economía chilena
el salario medio prácticamente se
duplicó en sólo 10 años y la renta per
cápita de este país llegó a equipararse
a labio argentino y precisamente es en
1988 cuando ocurrió algo único en la
historia reconozco y aceptó el veredicto
mayor y está el procesado del día y ayer
por la ciudadanía las presiones
internacionales obligan a pinochet a
convocar un referéndum preguntándole a
los ciudadanos si quieren que se vaya o
que se quede y lo pierde a partir de ahí
es cuando llega la democracia y en
contra de lo que mucha gente dice es en
este momento cuando realmente se llegan
a aplicar
de los chicago boys hasta sus últimas
consecuencias para todo cuanto también
quiero decir que una economía libre
necesita ir acompañada por elecciones
libres y democráticas un gobierno libre
democrático lexus durante la dictadura
muchos países habían aislado chile pero
ahora con una democracia era mucho más
sencillo firmar acuerdos de libre
comercio gracias a esto chile sí abrió
al mercado internacional de hecho todos
los gobiernos que se sucedieron durante
los años 90 e incluso parte de los 2000
pese a ser de centroizquierda
mantuvieron todas las instituciones que
habían diseñado los chicago bulls
en otras palabras si lees al libre
mercado lo que 300 es al cine
homoerótico su economía está entre las
10 más libres del mundo muy por encima
de eeuu es uno de los lugares con más
acuerdos de libre comercio su irpf el
tipo máximo es el 40 por ciento muy por
debajo del 56 que tenemos en españa y su
gobierno es pionero en políticas de
lucha contra la corrupción y
transparencia y para los economistas
liberales chile es un caso de éxito sin
precedentes
y desde luego si lo comparamos con sus
vecinos de américa latina' ganan por
goleada a día de hoy los chilenas son
más ricos que los argentinos pese a que
no tienen ni la cuarta parte de sus
recursos naturales por ejemplo el
porcentaje de gente que vive bajo el
umbral de la pobreza en chile es del 15
por ciento menos de la mitad que el de
su país vecino y lo mismo ocurre con
prácticamente todos los indicadores que
miremos esperanza de vida índices de
alfabetización renta per cápita etcétera
sin embargo mis queridos amigos
liberales y libertarios que sé que
muchos estáis viendo este vídeo contener
vuestro entusiasmo porque salir bien
parado cuando te comparan con argentina
brasil o venezuela es relativamente
sencillo incluso españa está mejor y
nuestras instituciones no son un ejemplo
de nada mucho menos del libre mercado lo
cierto es que tras 25 años con unas
instituciones que harían el sueño húmedo
de milton friedman la renta per cápita
chilena está por debajo de la de otros
países como hungría o grecia
es más si chile fuera un miembro de la
unión europea estaría entre los tres
países más pobres eso por no hablar de
la desigualdad que es una de las más
altas de todo américa
en visual político os hemos hablado de
muchísimos países que han salido
adelante gracias a instituciones serias
y libre mercado ahí está el ejemplo de
suiza liechtenstein o dubai sin embargo
en el caso de chile y algo que falla y
os voy a ser honestos no sé la respuesta
por supuesto que seguiré buscando
información y tratando de encontrar
alguna explicación a este problema pero
ahora mismo lo más honesto que puedo
hacer es preguntaros a vosotros qué
pensáis que es lo que creéis que falla
en chile porque no están a la altura de
otros países como australia podríamos
decir que chile es un pequeño fracaso
del liberalismo
podéis dejarme vuestra opinión en los
comentarios como siempre si alguno
quiere profundizar más en este tema
encontrará varios links en la
descripción del vídeo si os ha gustado
este vídeo dadle a like pronto os voy a
hablar de estonia el sillicon valley
europeo uno de los casos de éxito de
país más fascinantes que conozco
así que suscribiros porque de verdad que
va a merecer la pena un abrazo y hasta
el próximo vídeo